He was lying about [laughter] being a virgin this whole time.
>> It would have been No, it would have been heartbreaking
for you. >> You know, you waited your whole life to share
your virginity with a girl and [laughter] she threw it to some
frat house [__] 20 years ago. >> A white dude.
>> A white guy. >> A [__] WHITE GUY.
>> I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain.
[laughter] I'm in pain. I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain. >> You're
Dude. Dude, this is his I This is what he gets down what he signs
up for. >> This is what he signs up for. >> This
is when I close my laptop and I stop watching.
>> I'm [music] going to call an audible lab. How long you
here for? You're here for like an hour or two? >> Okay.
All right. We're going to do the AOS singing stuff. All right.
>> Okay. What is this? >> Yes. Let's um So, well,
I'll run the too lazy to try video.
Yes. Can we get Let's go. He He did a new update on the Akos
stuff, but we're going to watch we're going to watch Flagrant.
Okay. I just need to get live context on the Akos Singh stuff.
Yes. Yep. Yep. Yep. Oh, too lazy to try. I did a video on him
three years ago. That's crazy. Okay. This is the video.
>> Basically, this guy had arguments with Myron Gaines.
Walter.
What is Fresh? Was Fresh's last name? It's not Weeks, is it?
Is Walter Weekes?
Whatever. Walter. He had arguments with them about um how he
didn't like any of their ideas and how his wife was awesome.
And basically his wife is the biggest like on planet earth. Okay.
Like by far by far. Miles just the worst the worst person. Okay.
Incredible.
>> Like worse than me. >> Let's um
Yeah, definitely. Definitely the worst. Definitely the worst.
>> Let's give it a Let's give it a quick >> Like
what I find corny is is my preference is not my women. Now, I
thought it was I'm not dating my women, period. Which is the
corniest human being outside of a criminal to me. Period. It's
just those are your roots. Those women are reflected in your
roots. >> Akash is the extreme. Like Akash only dates Brown.
>> Oh, okay. Akash has been with one girl in his life who
is his wife. >> That's my wife. That's
loyal through and >> The way I look at it is, you know,
you watch them, you see them evolutionary charts from Neanderthal
to homo sapien. Y'all are the first out of Neanderthal, but grow
with your audience. Mature with your audience. >> One person
in the relationship, >> whoever cares less has the leverage.
And we want the guy to always care less. We want the man to always
have the
>> You guys, you guys might not like hearing that.
>> but we truly feel >> I'm not I'm not These aren't
new beliefs, bro. You're not telling me some none of us have
ever heard. We all heard >> I mean, I'm married. Akash
is married. Mark is married, right? Like, it's possible. Now
granted, we might call you in 10 years and be like, "Y'all were
right." [laughter] You know what I'm saying, bro? >> All
right. So, three years. >> So, that's the that's the prelude.
That's three years ago. That's the prelude to what happened.
Started popping off like about a month >> ago, Fresh and
Fit went on Flagrant and Schultz and the whole crew, especially
Akos, called them out for some of their controversial takes and
how they run their show, which obviously started a beef that
reignites every now and then. And it just did recently because
Myron discovered Akasha's wife is trying to be an influencer
and has her own podcast, which Myin's been having a field day
with because she's the exact kind of girl they warn guys about
and she constantly humiliates Akos on social media. Like people
just keep finding worse and worse clips and it's painful to watch.
I mean, this girl, she's up there with Jada Pinket Smith, which
>> Yeah, she's I mean, >> basically, you get a good
idea of why he's why. Yeah, basically everything that is happening
here kind of makes sense. Okay, you just need to watch. >> And
it's painful to watch. I mean, this girl, she's up there with
Jada Pink and Smith, which she'd probably take as a compliment.
That's how wild she is. So, I just wanted to warn people before
I get into this, the cringe is almost unbearable. Like, every
guy watching this is going to die inside a little. So Akasha's
wife, I think she's 10 years younger than him, and she's trying
to be an influencer, so she doesn't make any money, but she spends
his money like crazy. Most of her videos are like shopping vlogs
and vacations. And when she was asked if they split finances,
she said his money's our money and my money is my money, which
Akos sounds really stressed out about. Like she had him on their
podcast and he started flipping out about how she basically won't
do anything except spend his >> For those of you who are
new here, hi, my name is Justine. I'm a stay at home wife, but
I don't cook or clean cuz I don't feel like it. And my husband
is a full-time stand-up comedian, and he buys me lots of nice
things. >> When I say I'm >> You see it, right? You
feel it? You see
why like every guy on the internet, even a lot of feminists,
hate this woman. You see it? You see it? >> Uh I think
that there are I think there are plenty of relationships that
this like works for them. I like I understand the like the male
urge to be like this is soed up but like a lot of men are very
happy in this scenario and so are women. So I don't know. >> I'm
just going to keep every like 2 minutes or so I'm going to pause
and I'm just going to temp check. Okay, we'll see. Trust me.
>> Going to get >> tired. She can't just let me be
tired. I travel. I work and I'm very blessed to do what I do.
But when I tell my wife I'm tired, I want her to say I'm sorry,
baby. I understand that must be exhausting buying me all these
things. Instead, she goes, "Ah, so am I." And if I dare open
my mouth to go, "What the did you [laughter] do that made you
tired? Now it's a problem. Now it's a fight." So, I sit there.
>> I went to Pilates. >> OH, THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
YESTERDAY, I worked the entire like morning to night, whatever.
I finally I get a workout in cuz I'm trying to be less fat. And
then she's like, "Babe, can you take out Happy? I'm so tired."
And I'm like, "Are you [__] kidding me?" And then
I take you to MUI. >> That's reasonable, right? He's being
reasonable right now. >> Of course, he's being reasonable.
Yeah.
>> When you buy whatever you want. That's the bare. >> Excuse
me, N. I didn't buy whatever I wanted. He limited me. I am on
a budget. >> Because you want a house that I don't care
about. A house >> in the Hampton. This is the Hampton's.
>> And this girl is so out of control. She has hardcore
feminists feeling bad for Akos. Like in one of her most popular
Tik Toks, she's yelling at him because she doesn't have enough
room in her closet for all of her clothes and handbags. And the
top comments are like, "I'm sorry for that man, and I'm almost
never sorry for a man." And, "Girl, please don't make me side
with a man. Girl, don't make me agree with him, >> Do you
know what my husband just tried to do to me? >> No, no,
no. We're leaving. Shut up. We also just redid our closet. >> This
is all her closet now. She took the whole closet. >> Have
space for Can you show? Yeah. Yeah. >> I don't have space.
>> Oh my god. >> I'm not doing that. >> How
much space exists? >> I'm not doing that. We were supposed
to build a wardrobe, but Akash didn't want to do it too because
I took a smaller >> Do you know how much space he has?
Look, utilize the shelves, you idiot. Aash, for real, I like
my clothes spread out then. No, but like don't I don't want them
all on the same rack. So, it's really bad and it just keeps getting
worse. You know, I'm sure people are stressed out just watching
this because also when she's not spending Akash's money, she's
publicly humiliating him on social media to try to make her own
money and jump start her career. I mean, she has this dude completely
wrapped around her finger because also she's the only girl he's
ever been with. And
>> now that's true. She's the She's the only girl he's
ever been with. Okay.
I'm not gonna I'll let him explain. Okay, I I'm not going to
I'm not going to tell >> wise he's out of his league which
comes with a price literally. So she knows she has all the leverage
and she acts like it. I mean Akos, he's out there working all
day so he can afford her lifestyle while she sits at home reminiscing
about her time in college. >> Sometimes I get so painfully
nostalgic for college. So for context, I went to college from
2011 to 2016. I was popping my and living my best life in these
white boy frat houses and I had a roster of guys that I would
rotate through. So it's like
sometimes [cough and clears throat] it like literally hurts my
heart and when the nostalgia is that painful. >> My wife
also hadn't had any partners so that helped us connect a lot
more. >> Let me ask you this. Do you believe her?
>> So some
so that was like way before this. He put that on tape and then
she put out the pop in my these white boy frats. That's that's
rough, right? >> To be to be I mean there's two things
happening right now. One is she could having a roster is like
for a woman could just be men who give you attention, not necessarily
that you sleep with, but it's still embarrassing to say like
that. Two, like this is his fault. Like he's allowing this. >> No,
hold on, hold on, hold on. One one she said popping my anding
living my best life at these white boy frats and I had a roster
of guys I'd rotate through. I feel like people you put all that
together pretty unamiguous what she
>> No, cuz people I mean people could like go dance at
a party but >> Okay. All right. Fair enough. Yeah, fair
>> Popping your doesn't ever mean sleeping with someone
that's why I didn't just yell at you and say no. Okay. Okay.
I said that's why I said, "Okay, all right. All right. All
Why did you include the white boy part? >> No one needs
to take your phone away." >> Attention from whites and
Indians think that that's like a big deal. >> So you said
it's his fault though. He's allowing this. He's allowing this.
Yeah. >> Yeah. He like you if you're especially if you
have like all the money and you're like still giving her everything
and she's doing this to you, like you actually like it. Oh, that
is that might be the most popular theory is that he actually
has like a like total financial domination thing and like maybe
even a public humiliation thing and that this is like really
just an extension of their fetish that we're all participating
in by watching this. But I will say >> a lot of guys like
having like kind of a stupid hot wife who takes all their money.
Like not even that's not even like fendom. That's like a lot
of men just like that dynamic. Like they think it's like funny.
A lot of men think like my wife, my husband for example, like
he thinks that that's like a fun dynamic
like they like a lot of men romanticize certain relationships.
>> Okay. I don't uh maybe maybe outside of this stuff.
Okay. Not in the field like sorry. I could see how maybe some
normal guys who don't really engage in like a ton of online stuff
might romanticize certain aspects of that. Okay. I think obviously
the way he's talking about it, maybe even he does with the financial
stuff. The financial stuff he doesn't seem to give a [__]
about, right? Like he's he doesn't like ever, but he seems super
insecure about the thing and that he was a virgin and he thinks
that she was he put this on tape way before she was like an influencer
or wanted to be an influencer or anything. Right. >> So,
like I feel like she just didn't know about this. Like she probably
told him this and probably just didn't know that he had shared
that with other people. like this is years ago. >> Let
me ask you this. I do believe her.
>> So, someone needs to take her phone away. I mean, that
was brutal. I almost feel bad for Akos, but he's probably just
like, "Hey, at least she's doing something other than spending
my money." And obviously, he should have known what he was getting
himself into, but he was in denial. Like, the most disturbing
thing is she's obsessed with her podcast co-host husband. It's
so uncomfortable. like she'll talk about >> this is not
going to be one that I think you and that you could identify
with >> how attractive he is all the time and she'll bring
up his dick and she's begging them to have an orgy with her and
she's also even like Akash is great and everything but I think
your husband might be even better. This guy is just such a [__]
king. Like everyone knows he's the best husband and I
don't often find men that measure up to him and like Nav completely
measures up to him if not more. Can I just say your h like not
in a weird way, he's so good-looking. Oh, thank you. >> Would
y'all ever have an orgy together with [laughter] your husband?
Ria,
I'm actively trying to have an orgy because this couple is so
good-looking and you haven't seen Nav yet, but wait till you
see him. His body goes crazy. His face card always slays, never
declines.
>> It's important to note these are different podcast episodes.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Yeah, I know. Sorry. I guess I noted
that they're different podcast episodes. Like, it's consistent
that she does talk about these things. It's kind of weird cuz
I'm talking about your husband. No, I kind of look at it, but
I'm like us for it. Okay, maybe. Maybe. >> I just know
that Nav's
is like at least 10 in. He would only be down for an org. >> Or
it's thick. It's thick. I'd only been down for
>> That's That's crazy, right? >> I would never say
anything like that about another man. >> I This one I also
think >> are they in LA? We'll see if he includes
Rob or New York. Oh, dude. Uh, Flyrren has to be in New York,
right? NYC. Fly. Yeah, cuz they they talked about a house in
the Hamptons. That has to be New York, right? That's where New
York like you can go to the Hamptons. You can commute from the
Hamptons to New York >> Extremely fair. And I'm again,
I know nothing about these people. I know many couples in a dynamic
like to where they would not get offended by something like this.
My husband would literally
me if I'd said something like that. Um, and I would never want
to humiliate my husband that way. But there are plenty of people
who do not care about stuff like this.
>> Well, see, oh, but okay. Yeah, I think that's maybe
the most reasonable explanation here for their stuff. But here's
the thing.
Here's another fact. Okay. You can't say that you're into this
stuff and then be like cool online,
right? like he his job is to be like cool kind of like respected
cool edgy as a comedian. I don't think you'd be like yeah I'm
just like super into being I don't think you can do that man.
I think that's like ah
that's crazy. And the watch the clip coming up. Okay. The next
clip is crazy. >> Yeah. So this is just sad to see. I mean
it sounds like Akos is a good husband. You know he tries to do
everything right. He spends all this money on her, but it's not
enough. And she still feels the need to publicly humiliate him
and try to hook up with her friend.
Even Adam 22 couldn't do it. Adam22 couldn't pull it off. He
couldn't pull off looking like a making it look cool with like
a huge other women all the time. Having the most one of the most
successful podcasts on the internet, having like a whole [laughter]
network of podcast.
>> I I I've never seen it. I just said it because he's
aar who otherars.
It's >> He doesn't have a big dick.
That that that would be baffling to me. Why is he a star if he
doesn't have a big dick? >> A lot of stars don't have big
>> Oh, okay.
All right. I It's bigger than average. Do not lie. Do not lie.
Don't lie. Wait, what am I what am I lying about? >> He's
no goon. He's no goon. I'll tell you that much. >> Okay.
Um it's all camera angles. What am I saying? I'm lying about
this. I don't even know, man. I just I assume like I made the
assumption this guy sells this guy's got like an Only Fans where
he sells with his wife and like other stars. I assumed that he's
just like a big dick or some [__] but maybe not.
>> His husband like also they actually had their husbands
on the show and Akos's wife again makes it very clear that she's
really into this guy. Like she keeps hitting on him right in
front of Akos and the guy's wife too. You know, her co-host I'm
sure is kind of uncomfortable about this. Like it's just so awkward.
She has no respect for Akos and he's like, "Yeah, I think the
guy's great, too." But it's kind of annoying how great he is,
which he's probably annoyed that his wife clearly wants to be
with him and she doesn't even try to hide it. Like, she brings
up the orgy again and his and then said she's really nervous
about meeting his dad for some reason. I mean, she just cannot
help herself and Akos, he just sits there and takes it, you know?
I guess he's at the point where he just has to let her do whatever
she wants. So, this is just such a mess. I can't believe it's
real. You know, I feel like somebody needs to step in and just
be like, "All right, this is too far. You guys can't be doing
this podcast anymore. This is too much embarrassment." And of
course, she's giving My from Fresh and Fit all the ammo in the
world to go after a Kos. >> And can I can I say this is
the best husband I've ever seen. And I'm not even saying that
hyperbolically.
It's a little annoying. And then like he's just getting in better
shape. >> Her off already. >> Oh, what are y'all
doing this whole [laughter] time? Drake is your Taylor
>> I'm toxic. I How do you think I have to keep up with
her? No, [laughter] he be saying some boss ass [__]
What is the stuff he says to you that I'm just like that's fire.
>> No, now just puts his out on the table. >> There's
a being a scammer and >> what the [__] >> That's
that's when it's Yeah, that's uh But here's the thing. I think
he's kind of into that. I I think he's into it to be honest with
you. >> And being a hustler, two very different
husband. I don't see Indians as people. I don't these I it these
pe these two don't even register to me as men. >> These
people get such a bad rep on the internet. Dude, just be nice,
man. What the [__] dude?
We love Indian people here. Okay, we love Indian people here.
As it's really I'm a hustler who scams a little bit. [laughter]
I'm not a scammer who >> I lie that was and that's why
I'm actively trying to have an orgy.
>> Wait. Um, he used to sell like iPhone.
>> Dude, he used to sell iPhones. Wow. Who could have seen
this coming? Who? >> That first reaction is rough. Okay,
that first reaction.
That's like you're going to That's That's tough, man. >> He
used to sell and that's why I'm actively trying to have an orgy.
>> Wait. Um, he used
>> Dude, that's that's
it's not good body language, is it? looking down at the floor
trying to avoid eye contact with anybody in the room when she
says that.
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry, man. That's not >> Sell
like iPhones. Buy iPhones and sell >> Have you seen his
Instagram thumbnail?
>> Guys with dead end jobs usually got huge dicks. They
need to bring something to a relationship. Bro, >> I've
shown that to multiple dudes.
>> He has under
my wife's podcast partner's husband. [laughter] It's crazy. Ain't
that crazy? I've shown it to multiple guys. I've also shown it
to multiple >> if I'm meeting >> okay that's worse
now right isn't that like worse on his end to say that about
the guy I need to know the the chronology of that is that in
this is that like back to back that that happens where Akos goes
yeah actually she just said she wants to see this guy's dick
and wants to have an orgy with him I think he's hot too I show
his picture to all kinds of guys no shot right that's >> oh
this dynamic is strange
>> it's not dad tomorrow and I will say I'm nervous because
he has the not to be aware, but he has big dick energy and he's
obviously >> based off stories. >> Yeah, he is. >> She's
She's talking about this guy's dad now. Not just him, but like
his dad. >> His dad has big energy. This is her husband,
by the way.
>> he's a dawn. Let's face it. But thank you guys for being
on the main character pod. We love We hate you. We love you,
but I actually love you and want to all >> Yeah. So hopefully
Akos can get >> out of this mess because it only seems
to be getting worse. Like this relationship is not good for him.
But of course, I don't think he'll ever be able to leave her.
And Schultz, he has to be somewhat aware of this stuff. Like
he said he really wants Akasha's wife's career to blow up. So
then she has all the leverage in the relationship, which would
probably mean she'll leave him. I mean, she already has all the
leverage, but if her career blew up, then that's probably going
to happen. So maybe Schultz thinks that's the best outcome because
Akos is never going to leave her. But let me know what you guys
think. And I just covered Tony comedian William Montgomery completely
bombed out a show recently. It was hilarious.
Don't care. Okay. You missed one of the best clips though about
her. Like basically the idea was everybody thought there's like
a bunch of other clips. Like basically people found way more
clips. Like if I just search Akos Singh, okay, people farmed
this was like the biggest just millions of views across all of
YouTube. Millions and millions and
>> with him and his wife. Okay. Over the past couple days,
it's been or past couple weeks, it's been crazy. Like tons of
every commentary person's commented on it. Every like commentary
or every comedy commentary channels commented on it. Uh Aba and
Abba and Preach made like so much hate out of this. Hold on.
ABBA and Preach, they got so much out of this. 466,000 views,
355,000 views. They just did like pure Akash Singh content for
like a week. It's been nuts. So yeah, it's been it's been crazy.
But finally he decided to go they they brought the podcast back.
Flagrant they brought it back. Okay. And because they were on
a break. So the podcast where he actually works
>> the podcast where this a sing guy actually works. >> You
know who Andrew Schultz is, right?
>> I think so.
>> Yeah. He does like this flagrant podcast is like really
huge. Gets like millions of views on YouTube. Okay. Two million
subscribers. and and Schultz is like the big guy on it, but then
there's Akos Singh's been there forever and he's there and his
wife comes on and they try to do like a damage control episode.
Okay,
we'll see. We'll see how it goes. 64,000 dick dislikes versus
13,000. Jesus not fans.
>> Dick likes.
>> Damn. People are not fans. Yeah, I'm I'm like underplaying
it. Trust me. The response to this was unlike anything I've ever
seen on the internet. It was like uniform hatred and all of their
videos basically every video they posted since every video they
were posting before this are all spammed with comments like address
Akos address Akos address the AOS stuff. So they kind of had
to come back and say something
and they were famous for having Trump on right before the election.
Okay. I mean they're famous for lots of stuff. I think Andrew
Schultz is pretty big in the whole like comedy
I I want to say comedy mothership but I think he's sort of adjacent
to that. I don't think he's quite a part of it. He's just gotten
like very very famous. So,
because people have been wanting to take down Schultz for ages.
Well, the funny thing is is like this doesn't really reflect
on Andrew Schultz at all, but how he handles it after the fact
is going to reflect on him a little bit, I guess. I still I think
that's pretty unfair. I think he could just say, "I don't care."
People should have to like stop going after him, but that's not
the way people work. Tonight on Flagrant, the truth will be revealed,
marriages will be shattered, friendships destroyed, nothing will
be the same again. Our guest, once a beloved comedian, has spent
the last couple weeks being destroyed, disrespected.
He's been dragged through the mud and he spent the last couple
weeks being
>> Wife destroys Akos Singh's career. Whispers from behind
the scenes. >> Disrespected. He's been dragged through
the mud and he couldn't even take out that tiny little of his
and stuff it inside for his own pleasure.
Give it up for our friend here to tell his side of the story.
Akos Singh.
>> Brother, thank you so much for being >> Thank
you for having me. >> You can't imagine what you've been
going
>> through the last few weeks. Tell us what's been on your
mind, what's been on your heart. >> I'm so glad you asked
me, man. It's been it's been really hard for me. For me hard.
OH MY GOD. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Is in the building. She wants vengeance.
SECURITY IS HERE. SECURITY IS STOPPING HER. THE PUN IN POWER.
OH MY GOD. SHE'S ABUSING THE SECURITY GUARD.
IT'S ABSOLUTE PANDEMONIUM.
>> She's actually so bad at acting. She really is not good
at anything. What the
>> At least it was believable. Akos seemed a little sad.
IS SHE THIS [laughter] >> HAS BROUGHT OUT COMICALLY LARGE
SCISSORS. HE'S CUTTING THE HAIR. OH MY LORD.
THIS IS A PODCAST.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> Tonight on
>> I see the dislikes. I know people are not going to like
it. Here's the thing. I don't think the truth of the matter is
it would not matter how Andrew handles this. Okay, it is awful,
but it wouldn't matter how Andrew handles it. The whole audience
has already decided that Akos got to go. Unless he handled this
by like murdering Akos Singh live on the stream, live on the
podcast. I think he basically can't get out of it, right? It's
like he would have had to do like a double surprise. Okay. Well,
it's not a surprise Jasine's there, but he would have had to
Yeah. bring like Navin or something and like actually had a like
some kind of goofy conversation. Some kind of actual drama-filled
conversation. Pull up the comments real
I'm a shy Indian girl. I have two butt full stories.
She did tell Oh, that was one of the stories she told. One of
the clips we missed was her talking about how she got drunk and
went home with a guy or brought a guy home and then woke up with
a sore in the morning and then you have a sitting there. It's
like my why my my wife's so pure when I met her. Oh my god, she's
so perfect. Which is just
And he means it too. Like he literally means he thinks she's
a virgin and is so >> She's getting right into it. Yes.
Which frat party should my daughter avoid? I have a 2-year-old
daughter. Which frat party should she not go to? >> Shy
should avoid teik because they [laughter] definitely
>> they make you pop that thing crazy or what? [laughter]
>> Spike the drink. >> No way. >> Yeah. So
they got kicked off of our
that way. >> Oh my lord. Popping. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let's just get some definition.
We're We're gonna any terms that you might need to know the actual
meaning of Alex is here to break it down. >> I thought
it was just like
>> Teik was the loser frat at FSU.
TK Teik.
Was that anti-semitism from an Indian person? No way. Never seen
that before.
>> Israel is >> dancing getting dressed up and maybe
that was my mistake.
>> So I acknowledge that. >> Look at this big one.
>> Yeah. The act of getting dressed up, looking fly as
hell, wearing a minimum of 3 in heels, preferably higher, and
dancing your ass >> urban dictionary we hours of the morning.
That was what I was doing. >> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Did we finish >> That'sical to men and women alike. >> However,
usually referring to women and gay men, straight men have also
known to pop. However, they must be able to master or outperform
others one or more of the following: twerking, Jersey Turnpike,
Soulja Boy, the stripper/ lady of the night pole seduction moves.
Okay.
>> preferably higher and dancing your ass off into the
wee hours of the morning. That was what I was doing. >> Yeah,
this is white people's definition [laughter] of it. This is what
you learn. Don't go to Guys, what do you think popping?
>> Unfortunately, this is one of those things where we're
going to try to like address each of these individually and discredit
them individually, but like as a group. Okay. She said getting
popped. No, no, no. She said Poppy my
she said Poppy my
which could mean the dancing thing. Okay. But then she has to
explain why she told her husband she's a virgin but she's gotten
her ass fingered on multiple occasions that that's like
>> Yeah. She like woke up she either got in the or fingered
in the I don't know which. Said her assh was really sore in the
morning when she woke up. Yeah.
You see
>> Joey Curs is not that. [laughter] >> Oh yeah.
She also admitted to being to bleeding while she was getting
eaten out that her boyfriend didn't like that. That like she'd
wait to get past her period and she wanted to [__]
her boyfriend and so she was like, "Oh, I'm done." But she wasn't
quite done. And then he like made her feel gross. Cuz he was
like, "Oh, that's gross." You know? >> Okay. They do it
more than security. >> That was my bad. That was my bad.
>> That was that was your badiction.
Give me just give me a call every time. anytime we're worried
about anything like that. >> That's what I thought as a
white. I thought P was just dancing. I thought I was like working.
>> That's what I thought. >> Well, I knew that that's
what you meant. >> Yes, that's right. >> But like
once the internet makes you a
>> They're looking at
Joe. We're done. We're friends.
That's my wife for the time being. >> Do they have like
black midgets on retainer? Are these guys like recurring characters?
Cuz they're acting like they know them quite well. Are the black
[__] guys recurring characters? What's going [laughter]
on? >> We have a calcium market. By the way, we have a
calcium market. There's a calcium market that's been made. Will
Akasha just leave divorce before 2027? I just want to point that
out. Okay.
>> Uh I I don't think so. Another big part of what they
talked about was how she didn't sign a prenup and that she's
like entitled to a whole bunch when they divorce. If they divorce,
we have like a long way. >> Yeah, we got to go. We got
to rebrand you right now. [laughter]
>> Okay. some I got to wait that long.
>> Can we get some other definitions out of the way? >> Yeah,
let's get some other definitions. Yeah. Allegedly, and you can
correct me if I'm wrong here. Is it true that you said that there
was a rotation of guys? >> A roster. >> Yeah. What
is a roster? What does that mean? What does this mean? >> You
guys have to understand, have you ever heard of the repressed
Catholic school girl? >> I would.
[laughter] >> My my face when my friends are questioning
my wife being like a
>> bro. Well, I don't even think he like he probably doesn't
care. It's just so embarrassing that he was like saying how important
it was that she was a virgin and it's like how they connected
and that's like the only embarrassing part. Okay, realistically
he could be fine with that. Like, hey, maybe he likes that she's
a Okay, a lot of guys like that or totally fine with that, right?
Somebody who's experienced. But it's he said the opposite. He
basically implied the opposite by saying how important it was
that she was a virgin. Okay.
Yeah,
[laughter] I >> also the other weird thing for me is I
don't I didn't watch Akos before this. I didn't see anything.
He looks permanently depressed. He looks like actually depressed
all the time. Like he just genuinely has a depressed look about
him. Yes. So I don't know how much of this is him looking like
soul shattered because he always looks soul shattered or if his
soul is being >> I'm not sure which. Like he actually just
looks he's been looked to he's looked totally devastated in like
everything I've seen of him. Like his soul has been like totally
TK. Uh what is it? Shang Tsung. Shang Tsung took him. Speaking
of Shang Tsung, guys, absolutely. FS in the chat right now. Shang
Tsung died. He's such a good actor, but Shang Tsung has passed
away. Very sad.
>> Had to get the reference in. Okay. Your soul is mine.
What? Oh, rest in peace. Yeah. Yeah. In the chat. Yeah. Love
this Guy's a good actor. Really good actor. Really cool. But
he gone. Okay. Anyway, let's get back. >> Yeah. What is
a roster? What does this >> You guys have to understand.
Have you ever heard of the repressed Catholic school girl? >> I
was
[laughter]
Catholic school. >> Wait, hold on. I got to see the individual
reaction. >> Yes. I was
>> Yes. Andrew Schultz. Yes, I do know about this. [laughter]
>> His Catholic school was in his living room. Imagine
how repressed he was. >> I was a repressed Indian girl
that I didn't even watch Jersey Shore in high school because
I felt it to be too inappropriate. So when I got to college,
I'm like, "Oh my god, I can dress however I want. I can do whatever
I >> You can have a roster of crap.
>> What does a roster mean? >> So it didn't actually
translate to a roster. It just meant like two guys I was talking
to and flirting with at the same time. That's it. >> That's
all. And when you say hooking up, I think people think you meant
>> dude. Uh, okay. This has to throw you off, right, Lav?
When when she's like obviously lying about what that means.
>> No, I don't technically mean that. >> Plenty of
women who have a roster and they're not any of them.
>> Yes.
But two,
that girl too. >> There's no way it was just two with how
hot she is.
>> That's what I'm saying. I'm saying she's It's like so
unbelievable if she just picked a more believable lie.
Oh, I I didn't realize that when I dressed up I realized it got
attention and like guys would help me out with everything and
I just rotated through these guys taking attention from them.
I think it had a lot to do with like why I'm such a now. She
could say not quite that but basically that and she could like
save herself but she's like two I meant two guys. She does. To
me, she comes off as >> she comes off as a woman who has
not had a lot of experience with men and that's why she is the
way that she is. The the men the men who think that like weathered
women act like this are like this is a this is a woman who has
never been
like >> Oh, I just don't think she had
>> Yeah, I just don't think she had relationships. I think
she probably I think she probably dudes. I just don't think she
had very many relationships and she was probably dating most
of the
>> I don't think she comes off as someone who has.
>> Okay. Oh, this is another plausible theory. Uh, can
we get some Wait, I almost said something crazy.
Almost said something crazy.
Um, >> can we find out if she was fat as a kid? >> She's
we kind of chubby in half of her >> No, no, she wasn't.
>> I just meant making out again. Like everything I say
is so amplified and hyperbolic because it's so like inongruous
to who I'm actually who I actually am as a person. >> Right.
Right. So you you're saying you're a big old prude.
>> Okay. Now this is probably the best like the best compromise
they could have done was just her come out and say like, "Oh,
I made all that up. You shouldn't trust me at all." Like I was
just totally griffing for social media. I just want >> She
can't do that because she still has to sell her brand. >> Well,
no. She is doing that right now. She's literally saying that
this is like I I just implied something that was like not at
all congruent like congruent with what I actually am, who I actually
am. Like that's what she's saying here, which is fine cuz her
brand is not worth anything. The flagrant brand and Aasha's brand
are worth a lot, right? Like she might want to make her brand
bigger or something. Maybe she can eventually, but like um if
she has to make a sacrifice to say somebody's in the wrong here,
it's got to be her, right? To save Akos and save everything else.
No, I think that if you're trying to do like a call her daddy
type podcast, you can't admit that you're like a liar and you're
actually approved. Uh, >> yeah, I think so. But I'm saying
that she has to give that up basically if it if it's between
her career and Kasha's career. One of them gets a house in the
Hamptons. The other one gets them nothing. Literally nothing.
>> She's more likely to make more money than he is on something
like a Caller Daddy podcast. So,
>> uh, maybe >> like women women are the consumers
of podcasts that like actually have like longevity.
I' like I've never heard of this guy before.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. I I agree with you that women consume
a lot more media and so there's but I don't think she's got
>> I maybe I'm wrong. I just don't think she's got it for
she yaps.
I don't know. I don't think I've ever seen where women will follow
her like you don't need to have much for
>> women to buy whatever you're selling to them when you
look like that. >> Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Kid says she'll never be at the level he's currently at as a
sidekick. He won the lottery. He did kind of win the lottery
with flagrant. Okay, this this podcast is worth a of money. Like
a ton of money.
Anyway, we can uh we can keep watching. She's just not very good
at it in my opinion. She's not very funny. She's not very like
she could get better. She's got like an attitude. She certainly
has
>> Well, she has the personality defect I think you need
to like I I don't want to talk Nick cuz he's become a very big
streamer. But like Nick Lee, Amaran's husband, that guy's got
like the personality defect that makes him like an amazing streamer.
Like I I knew from the moment I saw him, I'm like, "Oh, this
guy can never stop yapping. He's like super self-absorbed. He's
obsessed with himself. Like he can be good." I think she's got
something like that where if she could get it like charged or
channeled in the right way, it could be good, but maybe more
as a streamer or something. I >> Yeah, I don't know. >> Yeah.
I don't know. Nick's like I don't I don't mean that to talk about
Nick cuz there's some okay things about him, but he's um >> she
turned into a good streamer. No, he was a good streamer from
the beginning. I don't know how old she is. Uh college ended
in 2016. That'll put her at 22. So 22 about 30. Round about 30.
Yeah,
Nick was a good streamer before. Nick was like somebody who could
be a good streamer before.
Hold on, let me move my what do you call my chat overlay here.
This guy over a little bit. There we go. [laughter] >> Now,
I will be honest. As much as I was heartbroken by what was going
on with you guys and definitely >> Nick is pretty actually
pretty cool. All things considered, Nick is like cool. I would
just say the thing about Nick is is he's like it's all there.
It's all like on its face. So, I don't have to like hate Nick.
I didn't he rocks.
>> I didn't Yeah, I didn't hate him like to begin with.
I thought it was really funny watching it. It's like dude, it's
actually I could see exactly how people would like gigachhat
a lot of this stuff. His interactions with his wife when he's
like gaslighting his wife and making her cry are pretty disturbing.
But outside of talking to his wife, like all the other stuff
is pretty funny.
Okay,
it's all very funny. >> You know, my brother, there was
a little part of me that was like, it would be hilarious to come
in here and find out you had a huge roster, was lying [laughter]
about being a virgin this whole time. It would have been heartbreaking
for >> You know, you waited your whole life to share your
virginity with a [laughter] girl and she threw it to some frat
house 20 years ago. >> A white dude. >> A white guy.
A [__] WHITE GUY.
>> I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain.
I'm in [laughter] pain. I'm in pain. >> I'm in pain. >> You're
dude. Dude, this is his I This is what he gets down. This is
what he signs up for. Holy [__] This is what he signs
up for. This is when I close my laptop and I stop watching.
>> Okay, never mind. Andrew Schultz is totally willing
to watch Akos jump off the Empire State Building to save his
own career. Okay, Andrew Schultz just said, "Yeah, you lost your
virginity to white dude. High five." And leaned over Akos to
high-five like he was dunking over Akos. He high-fives his wife
about her losing her virginity to a white guy. Holy [__]
What? >> A white dude. >> A white guy. A [__]
WHITE GUY,
I'm just going to watch this [__] his wife later,
>> dude.
Oh,
going to watch He's going to watch her get gangbanged by Andrew
Schultz and the security team. Okay. It's going to be >> So,
no real roster. >> Yes. Because what [laughter] a roster
is. What is a roster? What's a roster? What was a roster?
>> Dictionary. Indian dictionary. Right. >> Yeah.
Yeah. [clears throat] >> Teriction
[laughter] dictionary. >> Okay. Al, what is a roster, Al?
>> So, a roster. There's a rotation of >> uh partners
that you would they would pop their for me. >> No. Okay.
>> That what a roster would do. >> I didn't mean
>> women on my roster would be popping
>> I don't even like you saying that word like that. even
uncomfortable. With all due respect, >> all [laughter]
due respect, I have Thank
>> This is a good lesson.
>> I I'll be real. I do feel like to some extent
the idea that Akos would would do this would like let would say
the response here has to be like everybody mocking my wife for
being a [__] I feel like that's very like on brand
for him and
that he would like I totally understand how he would accept it
and I feel like you can't accept it. I don't know why. Bro, you're
going to go to comedy clubs after this. How the are you going
to go to comedy clubs after this? And the whole time you're like
going to headline or something and every opening act is just
going to be mocking you. You're going to have to go out and deal
with like all of them mocking you. Maybe this guy's like tough
as nails. I don't see it though.
You guys see it? I don't see it, man. >> Good lesson.
>> Okay, that's not >> Remember the black substitute
teacher in Ken Peele? That's that right now. He's really explaining
things to you. >> Any other questions about the world that
you have? >> No. [laughter] Also, why Buffalo chicken wraps
every day? >> Dude, dude, dude, dude,
>> dude. It's so
It's so over. It's like absolutely just totally completely and
utterly over.
He does nothing but crowd work. He's
>> bro. Me? >> How do you know that? >> YOU
POSTED IT ON [laughter] THE >> WAIT, I DON'T KNOW THIS
ONE. >> Is that what you call the black guys? >> NO.
NO. SORRY GUYS. Sorry [laughter] guys. Guys. Okay. >> No.
She calls them a Popeye's chicken
>> Okay. Wait. Tell us. What is the buffalo chicken wraps?
>> No, it's just literally I would just order buffalo chicken
wraps every day for dinner. It I think I think where the confusion
was is like I was just talking about this nostalgia for being
in college when it's like you're still a child, but it feels
like you're in the adult world and like you're so insulated and
you're in this bubble and like everything's just so simple and
easy. And that's more what I was talking >> Everybody thinks
you're a gold digging. >> There's a lot of reaching out.
>> You're a professional here. You're doing security. Okay.
[laughter] You cannot laugh at him calling his own wife a gold
digging. Okay. Okay. >> She told me to shut up. It's even
That [laughter] is fair. That is fair. Okay. Um also like in
>> it's some like dire stuff. Okay. I >> I'm in
>> I feel like this has to be this has to be what he's
into, right? It has to be like given given she talked about wanting
to her podcast co-host husband and his response was, "Oh, dude,
this guy's body's nuts. I've like sent it to other people, too,
and now he's doing this." It's like, bro, it has to be that you
just like this. You enjoy. >> To be fair, though, there
are men that just don't care about this. Like,
>> yeah, but Ive I've been in relationship with them. Like,
they just don't they just do not give a They just don't care.
>> I really hate to I I agree with you. I think you cannot
care. I think this is his job. This is like his place. And like,
man, I'm not I'm not always one Well, okay, I am always one for
reading body language for jokes, but like legitimately,
this is rough. It feels It feels rough. [snorts] This doesn't
feel like he doesn't care. It feels like I Dude, it feels like
he cares.
It's a little yikesy. >> I will ask that again.
>> Oh, get the [__] out of here. How did I
click on that? >> In terms of the gold digging. Yeah.
>> Like seriously, >> do you do you uh do you consider
yourself a good gold digger? >> Yeah. Because [laughter]
I invest in >> Okay. This is the one she can own and just
be happy about. Cuz she seems to have like pretty conclusively
said, "Yeah, this is me. That's who I am." And wait for it to
go high. >> You're a gold prospect. [laughter] Yeah. That's
not a gold digger.
Yeah. You're like a um h what is that? You're like a hedge fund
manager. >> Yeah. Yeah. You're like a Bitcoin. Exactly.
And it's like >> she bought much lower than I did [laughter]
because I bought it. She bought at the bottom. She could not
have >> that. Something that >> But to be fair, it's
like I was working too in the beginning and you weren't. Yeah.
What were you doing? >> I was I worked at I when we met
I worked at Goldman Sachs. I got a job at Deote after I graduated
college. I was a >> Sweeping in until 12 p.m. [laughter]
>> a gold digger.
To be fair, I think at this point, wasn't it that he was like
a comedian and he was successful and then he had like a down
period with their podcast and stuff. Okay, that was unexpected.
I mean, she would have gone to Yeah, it is a little unexpected
that she
I wonder what her role was. I wonder what her degree is. Does
anybody know? [laughter] >> You got this girl sleeping
on the >> Yeah, I know. This whole thing backfired. I was
saying I used to really believe that you guys were poor with
his Saab story so we could get Patreon going I didn't know you're
working at a hedge fund this whole time he was spending your
money. >> Well, I wasn't making that much. I was making
like 70 grand a year on in New York City on two people. >> But
that's good though. >> Yeah, it wasn't bad. >> Okay.
So then when did you guys get really broke and why did you stay
with >> 2018. Okay. Do you want the real answer or the
funny answer? I want I want to know the real answer and like
I want to know that cuz I heard this beautiful story that Akash
told about you guys sleeping on the floor and then like him wanting
to give you his north face or something and then you gave it
back cuz you're like it's not me. >> I'm [laughter] not
sleeping in North.
>> You saved your sleep on the floor with you in >> 2009.
A bachelor's science degree in finance and business analytics
from Drexel University.
Um, and then she got a master's degree in business and economic
reporting, business journalism at New York City, New York City,
h New York University's Arthur L. Carter Journalism Institute.
So, she's got an education.
[laughter]
>> No, but you guys were sleeping on the floor cuz you
were evicted from your apartment. You were moving to New Jersey,
right? This is real. And you still want to stay with him. >> Yeah.
I mean,
>> I never [laughter] actually asked why. >> No,
you know why, bro? Come on. Right back.
[laughter] >> You got that muffin top. >> Yeah, you
got that loud. Yeah. >> Um, okay. The real answer. >> What
is loud?
>> His smells. >> Oh, that dick. [laughter] >> Cuz
once you guys are profession,
>> Cuz he's Indian. That's why his dick
>> Security breaks out. >> Come on. You didn't make
sure. Okay. No, but for real, you got to stink husband sleeping
on the floor. [laughter] Like what's wrong with you, man? Like
you're supposed to be a gold digging
the >> That's what I'm saying. There was like so many red
flags early on. >> But why did you stay? That's >> okay.
I stay because I felt like as soon as I met you, it was love
at first
>> I loved you. Like I don't know. I just felt like and
maybe like you feel like that when you guys met your wives or
your fiance. It's like you just like know when you have that
special connection. And it's like, okay, like God picked this
person out for me and like everything he did from top to bottom,
like his character, his integrity, his personality, like I just
like loved everything about it. So I was like, okay, like I don't
want to just leave because we're going through a hard time because
I really believed in like his potential like just like you did
for sure, you know? >> Uh, evil Johnny Bravo. That is
that's something people don't talk about that like uh this is
there's an element of pretty privilege that if you can get a
degree that that makes you eligible for an internship and you're
a hot girl, you're going to get an internship somewhere big.
I I'm sorry. It's like it's just true.
And usually they could pick up the job on the fly, right? But
if you've got the qualifications to like to at the bare minimum
qualified for some internship, some big company's going to hire
you. Yeah, I feel like I know exactly what you're talking about.
>> Because obviously you were more successful than Akash
like in the very beginning and stuff and now you guys >> Yeah,
whatever,
I also believe that he was incredibly brilliant and talented,
but also just an amazing soul and an incredible person. >> Exactly.
But I just know I also knew that about him that he had like ambition
and this work ethic. So I was like, "Okay, like >> so we're
going to go through this bumpy time." But I was like praying
harder than I ever prayed just that we would get out of it and
like something would resolve. And I was just hoping that >> and
it worked. Those prayers worked >> and you haven't prayed
for his balls to
>> I never prayed for that. >> It just shows me that
you might like it. It's like it's like Vegomite for
>> That's women are bigger than pherommones. Yeah, there
is there is a way that that just kept you in something that is
possible. >> Carninal smell [laughter]
carnival smell. Carnival
>> Yeah. What is that? >> Carnival smell would be
better. It'd be like funnel cake. It would [laughter] be >> Okay.
The other thing that we saw these videos of was the uh the ducking
the kisses. That was those are Listen, these ones me off. >> I'm
guilty of I'm >> these ones me off and I didn't like it
one bit and I need you to explain yourself to me. >> Yeah.
Okay. >> Yeah, we need to know. >> Honestly, I I
>> Also, can I just say that I would watch the videos and
I would die [laughter] >> as a friend who loves him.
>> Dude, uh Schulz is kind of playing this exactly the
way he has to to make sure he comes out of this just fine. He's
just like he's every time he gets a chance to just dunk on this
guy, he goes for I would die laughing cuz they did they edit
it so perfectly where like he's going in and then [laughter]
just laughing. But he's already got his lips pursed so he got
to commit to the >> Yeah, we got to check. That was a shifty
edit right there. >> That might [laughter] shifty might
have been edited. >> Shifty made it.
>> Anyway,
so tell us about the the duck. Do you always dunk his kisses
when there are not people around? >> No, not when there
aren't people around. Just when there are people around. And
I never even knew. I never I didn't explain yourself. I didn't
know that I
>> I [laughter] didn't know that I did that. So, I really
sat and thought about it. So, I >> Man, now I'm sitting
here thinking like, do you think they scripted this? That was
funny. I thought that was funny. Finally, he got one in. Finally,
he had a moment. At least he had one moment in this entire podcast.
Okay, that was actually funny. It didn't seem like it was totally
the worst for him ever. >> I think it's a few things. I
think it's like, you really sat and thought about >> I
was like, "Okay, maybe it's like the repressed Indian girl thing
where it's like I get a little bashful. I do get a little shy
despite what the internet
>> me when I'm talking about my friend's
>> and getting your ass fingered and all the white boy
frats you have rosters from and >> like I I'm sorry." It's
like she does all this stuff where she's like super bashful and
then it's like but are you >> Most Indians do. Um, >> not
when it comes to that nav guy talking about his being 10 in and
super
>> I think I also get over stimulated because Akash does
it a lot. Like every 30 seconds. [laughter] >> I get it.
>> That's why I grabbed your chic.
[laughter] Whose mic? M. Oh, sorry. Okay. Suck that off you.
>> Okay. So So it is a little bit overstimulating for you.
>> Yeah. It like regulates him, but it kind of overstimulates
me. And like the videos people have seen are like the proposal
videos. They're like already over stimulating. >> Bro,
this is crazy. How [laughter] >> Wait, hold on. There's
a sore section.
When you said you woke up in the morning with a sore, did you
mean that you got finger blasted in the ass or what did you mean
exactly? Um, no. Actually, what I meant was like I kind of just
sat weird the night before and it kind of led to my ass being
sore in the morning and I sort of blew it out of proportion.
I didn't mean that that dude like finger bang my ass or anything.
I didn't mean >> Okay. So So here's the thing that I think
is
>> Yeah, she said that. Well, I mean she she implied that
a dude without consent like fingered her ass while she was sleeping
or something while she passed out. I think that's what she implied.
Pretty sure >> like very relat I think the relatable thing
is not wanting to make out with your partner in front of your
entire >> But most people just do it cuz they're like I
don't want my partner to feel embarrassed in this moment even
though they're like uh and you're just like you just feel the
you just feel [laughter] but but I do think it is I I do think
it's relatable though to have that sensation of like I don't
want to be intimate around my like brother sisters or mom dad.
>> Yeah. Exactly. I think that is re I think that's relatable
to people, >> but most people just do it and then do a
quick one. Like my wife will just give me like a quick smooch
and then go back to doing >> our parents kissing ever.
So it's like so foreign to us. >> This is an this is an
interesting thing that a lot of the internet might not understand,
but it's like >> your family your parents were not like
romantically in love at all. And would you say yours >> you
could cut romantically?
[laughter] >> Were they both arranged? Were the marriages
both? And sometimes arranged marriage, it's a free golf. They
love all the time.
>> But they don't show us. Even don't see >> Exactly.
Thank God. >> Yeah. [laughter] >> Show that to children.
>> Our kids are going to see it. >> Now, especially
the internet [laughter] has shamed her into not ducking. So >> Oh,
now she got no excuse. >> Yeah, that's true. >> Me
one. >> There we go. >> She can Can we settle something
for the
>> See, it's cultural. Um I'm sorry. the c what's the cultural
part about
what I don't know what the cultural part is. Okay. About all
of the stuff she talks about on her podcast. Where's the cultural
part?
I'm sorry. That's There's just no way.
>> I hate my husband core. Hold on a sec.
>> It's a compilation, guys, of her dodging the kisses.
[cheering]
>> You got to >> Saturday when I saw her, I said,
"Dario, do you know?" And she said, "I don't know anything. I
don't know any liar. Then she's a good liar. >> That's
a friend.
>> She's a good liar,
>> She's always just sneaking away. Just a little bit.
Sneak it away a little bit. >> I know.
>> Why not? >> I don't like I don't care about I
like tangible good.
>> I don't like I don't care about I
>> That can't be it. That is it. Okay. Wow.
Lot of lot of kiss dodging there. That didn't include the wedding
photos apparently. So, I think I've seen either a clip or photos
of her doing it while they're taking their wedding photos as
well. It's like, bro, how do you not how do you dodge the kiss
at your wedding photos? You should have a photo of you guys kissing
from your wedding in your like whole It was an Indian wedding,
too. You know, they dropped like 50k on that wedding and there's
not a picture of them kissing for their wedding. That's craziest.
Will you kiss a right now? >> I don't even know if I want
to see it.
>> Bring that ass over here. Bring that ass over here.
[screaming]
>> Oh, this is gigas scripted. Oh, this is giga scripted.
Oh boy. Oh boy.
>> You know how it's scripted? There's a very obvious tell
for how it's scripted. Do you want to know how I know? Do you
want to know?
>> Sure. The people who pop off the couch and like move
are the white guys and the black guy sits. Okay, if that was
actually something crazy that happened and there's a pop off,
that black guy would have been out of the room. Okay,
watch. Just watch,
>> bro. They're like doing it before it
>> Oh boy.
I'm sorry.
Ah, that's rough, dude.
It's scripted and it's not scripted in like the Nick Fentes way.
It's scripted in like the obviously scripted bad skit comedy
way. Okay. JESUS.
THIS GUY. THIS GUY. OKAY. [screaming] >> He's like a black.
[laughter] What the? That's amazing.
>> I do.
>> It was over stimulating.
>> It was over stimulating. >> Cross his leg. Shows
or show. I've won on the books. >> Sorry. I was going to
say this. Thank god. French Toast Mafia said it. Okay, this is
Kai that Thank you. Thank you. I didn't want to say it, but now
a black person has said it. This is Kaisenat, but two inches
shorter. Okay, this guy right here is just Kais, but two inches
shorter. Those two inches were critical to Kais being successful.
Okay, >> that cross his leg shows or show of
where we
in front of millions and billions of people. [laughter]
>> It was an act >> just two inches shorter. Okay,
hold on. Do you guys think I'm even joking? Is it like Kaisenat
is like comically short,
Kaisenat is like
he's like 5 foot one or five foot two. Like he nearly qualifies
as a [__] by himself. This is just like a very very
very very slightly smaller Kaisen. >> But can I just say
there's so many Tik Toks where I talk so positively about him.
And >> but why does that why that doesn't go >> Positively
talking about people. Yeah, but I was just saying I've like found
so many Tik Toks where I was saying so many amazing uplifting
things, but they didn't grab on to that. >> That will never
the internet will never reward positivity. >> Yeah, that's
true. Lesson learned. Unless Well, that is that is the tricky
thing. But it is it is a weird thing. It's like when you share
your life >> like as a couple publicly with the world,
you know, and >> rough you guys have like you guys have
like idiosyncrasies that are kind of different from a lot of
couples. Yeah. >> You know what I mean? Like apparently,
>> bro. Mhm. >> The orgy thing was
that [__] [laughter]
>> Was that an idiosyncrasy? The orgy thing. You guys got
or idiosyncrasies that are really different than other couples.
Like when she talked about really like thirsting for this guy's
10in Indian his Indian 10-in Coke can. Okay. Like holy. That's
an idiosyncrasy that a lot of people don't share. >> That's
crazy. I even watched it and I was like, so break us down. Give
me an explanation. Has the origin happened? So, okay. No, no,
it has >> Okay. No, that's the only one woman.
>> No, that's that's what I thought was
that's what I thought was missing in the whole orgy combo is
that he also gets to get some side. >> I could have doubled
my body count.
>> Now, would you have let him get some side in this hypothetical
orgy? >> Of course, everyone should be included, >> bro.
I could just see it right now. I could just see it right now
that if that actually did happen,
okay,
the the podcast co-host would be like, "Oh, actually, I can't
do it with Jasine." And then she'd be like, "Well, I still want
to do it with this other guy." And then he would sit there and
be like, "Okay, well, I can't just force this woman to [__]
me." [laughter] >> nas wants the dude. >> The dude?
>> You think he can handle all 10 in?
>> You think you can take Nav down or is Nav taking it?
>> Come on. Nav shorter than me. Who taking?
OH,
BAM. >> Now the bot and the dragging on the car. >> Little
little throwback to Andrew Schultz's totally deranged comments
Kot. Okay. Pretty crazy. [laughter] >> Like the dust.
>> Shout out Nav, bro. >> Yes. Shout out Nav, you
[__] home >> You guys Do you guys remember
that when he said he would Kendrick Lamar in prison because Kendrick
Lamar is shorter than him? He was like, "Yeah, if Kendrick Lamar
and me were in prison,
dude, it was crazy. [laughter]
Was this the wedding kiss dodge you were talking about?" Hold
on, let me pull it. Let me pull it up. Let me pull it up. What
is it? >> Him and then the first date and the first time
we kissed and the first time maybe his girlfriend and on and
on. I found so much love from him that at the wedding mark, I
didn't expectation for that feeling to increase. But that feel
>> I've seen pictures from their wedding and it's probably
from this stuff where like there's no picture of them kissing
everything where he's getting close to kissing. They're not kissing
where >> Yeah. Right there. No, this is the this is the
one from the wedding that I saw. This is the one from the wedding
ceremony that I was like yikes, dude. That's your wedding. You
got to have one picture at your wedding where you're actually
kissing, right? That's got to >> I feel even more love
from him THAN I >> OH, WAIT. NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. I FORGOT
ABOUT THE SHIPS PASSING in the night. Hold on. This is the best
part. They tried to fake it. They tried to fake it like it did
happen >> where I feel even more love from I ever thought
that I could.
>> That That is That is them faking it, right? You can
see that. Oh, Lav Lav's not here. Oh, no. Oh, no. She stepped
away at the most critical moment.
That is ship's passing in the night. Okay. There is no There's
barely any lip-on lip contact happening there at
>> Yes. Yes, it's the force perspective from Lord of the
Rings. She's been gone. Wait, have I been waiting for Lab's response
and she's been gone? Oh, no. No, she's here, but I thought she
disconnected from the Discord if that's what you guys were saying.
Oh, yeah. Look at the nose differences.
>> Dog D.
They had to fake they had to force perspective a kiss for their
wedding photos. thought that I could. And I just see how hard
he works to
be the best man that he could be. And
>> ooked with this one. This is a This is a good picture
for him, for his ego. Okay, that's a At least she did that. At
least she could look and pretend she was into him even if it
was from a distance. Okay. Wait, he looks like Adam 22 there.
I feel like you're seeing something spiritual that's not necessarily
showing in the face. Okay. >> Also provide for us. It's
something I really admire about him.
>> Okay. This is that was the photos I was talking about.
Yes. [laughter] >> Okay. What the was that joke? Cuz I
think for a lot of people, myself included, like I saw that and
I was like, why would she even joke around about that? >> With
Akos there. And like what was the No, I was the back. >> Now
looking back like it's been pointed out to me and I get that.
I feel like for us >> I think I learned so much of my humor
from Akash. Not to like justify it but just to explain like oh
if I say these absurd things it's so funny because it's not who
I actually am. But I kind of forgot that like the internet doesn't
know all these multi-dimensions of my personality. So they're
just seeing this one thing. So the orgy joke started with like
Akash being like oh Nav's really hot. like Nav would Akash would
show Nav's picture to his trainer or whatever cuz he's like really
like yeah ripped or >> I I will say also if she had a body
count I would have been like hey yeah cut cut that but because
she doesn't and I know how like innocent she actually
>> Oh you are
>> oh he's d he's doubling down.
He's doubling down. He's doubling down. He's doubling down. Uhoh.
Why? Just Just don't say this. All you have to do is not say
it. All you have to do is not say it and make it important to
you.
Just be like, "No comment. Just didn't don't comment. You don't
even have to say it's like not important. Is it?" You don't have
to say anything. But why put it on the record that you you need
to correct it. You need to make sure people understand that she
actually wasn't a she actually wasn't a Guys,
>> cut the but because she doesn't and I know how like
innocent she actually is. >> Oh, you are a version.
>> Guys, you don't understand. And she tells me all the
time about how she couldn't possibly suck dick. She finds it
so off-putting. She thinks sucking dick is the grossest thing
in the world. And then there's like 20 guys in college who are
like, "No, she doesn't." No, she's pretty fine with it. Right.
Like that. By the way, if you don't understand, that's what the
smelly dick comment was. That's what that was. I'm just telling
you. >> I didn't until I met him. Yeah. >> Oh, okay.
>> Uh the Wait, when did we ask about the boyfriend that
was eating you out? Wait, what? Hold on. Where's the boy? Now
we have to go find that boyfriend clip. What the? She literally
said I needed like or something like that. She says something
crazy. Hold on. Let's find it. Let's find it. Where is this one?
Where is this one? Where is this one? Come on. Come on. I should
be able to find it. Oh, come on, man. I can't find it. I can't
find it. >> I'll find it in some compilation. >> If
she wasn't that body count thing, I'd have been like, "What are
we doing >> Cuz I would have been insecure about it. I
I can be not that I'm so secure but with that joke I'm like so
secure. >> I absolutely would feel insecure >> and
I think stupidly I was like oh it's an orgy so it's all of us.
It's not like >> that is stupid. >> Yeah [laughter]
>> I say you're being inclusive. You're being inclusive.
>> It's not a roti though we're not doing this stupid.
Don't let me get other >> one [laughter] of our one of
our fans asked us what you guys have orgy. So I just said oh
I'm actively trying like as a cuz I just feel like >> can
I give you a piece of advice? Okay. >> If you clearly see
that I'm the one commenting those things [laughter] and answer
it on the podcast
Andrew Sh. Oh, you guys have an orgy on the podcast. You don't
have to react to that in real time. [laughter] >> Dude's
line yesterday. He was like, "This is so annoying. This whole
orgy thing like I can't even cheat without her there being there."
>> Yeah, that's [laughter] crazy, dude. >> Too much
quality time. Let's do something separately. You know what I
mean? But how come you can have a joke about outsourcing hand
jobs and [__] >> But aren't you cool with the
hand jobs? >> you're cool with him just getting a hand
job massage.
>> Are you act? >> Yeah, I know. >> Yes, I've
said that. It's less work for >> I don't This is I don't
[laughter] >> Can you talk to our wives? >> I don't
believe. Can I tell you why I don't believe you horrible decisions?
>> She was You guys were like, "Dude, I think your girl
will be down. She keeps saying how pretty Weezy is." And I was
like, Even then, I was like, "No, >> dude. I'm I'm literally
just trying to find this [__] clip of her talking
about the boyfriend in the period. God damn it. Yes. Yes. I'm
trying to find that clip right now. [__] me. >> Him
just getting a hand job massage.
>> Are you act? >> Yeah, I know. >> Yes. I've
said that. It's >> Oh, that's weird. That's also weird.
>> That's work for me. >> I know. This [laughter]
is I don't >> Can you talk to our lives?
>> I tell you why I don't You know her horrible decisions?
>> She was You guys are like, "Dude, I think your girl
will be down." She keeps saying how pretty Weezy is. >> What's
her channel? Uh, it's the main character pod here. I'll put it
in chat. [sighs and gasps] It's the main character pod. There
it is. >> And I was like, even then I was like, "No, the
she's all talk. She's all bluster." That's why I have it paper
>> She's a
>> She's our dog. She's a yapping little dog behind a fence.
Nothing's going to happen. There's [laughter] no bite.
All bark, no bite. >> So So you would say that, but in
reality, if he actually did go get it, >> okay, like let
me think about it. If you actually did go get it, yes. It's like
I think it would bother me like 30%, but I feel like 70% I'd
be like, "Okay, whatever." I put you through a lot the past [laughter]
couple weeks. >> Like he deserves it. >> I don't
I feel like I owe it to you. >> I do kind of deserve it.
Yes. And we're going to be supporting
so close to
You [laughter] >> wait. She can't be prettier than you.
>> Yeah. She just can't be prettier than >> Yeah.
Yeah. I mean Yeah. That's not going to Yeah. Unless you go That's
not going to happen. >> Yeah. It's going to be a old Chinese
lady. My also my justification for the hand job is it's emotionless
and it's a it's a >> it's just like a little thing after
a massage shirt. Okay. >> Yeah, that's a great I mean on
board
>> I also like the fact that you're it's just less work
for you and I know your day is full of >> so bad. It's
so bad, dude. Hold on. Let me look at flagrant too. See if I
can find it. I'm looking I'm looking I'm looking high and low
for this clip.
Uh
couldn't can't find it here. Hold on. All right, hold on. Jesus
Christ. Hold on. I just ca I just came across a thread of somebody
who went who went nuts. This guy went sicko mode. What the four
days ago? I watch all of Jasine's content to determine if she's
joking or actually disrespecting Akos. What the This guy watched
everything. This guy's got it all. What the hell,
bro? Dude, what the [__] man?
I'm sorry.
That's That's insane.
Now, hold on. Spotting
period. A men being sick, dude. Smelly balls. She talks about
a cautious smelly balls on Tik Tok. >> Hold on. >> Curious
to know like how do you guys handle things around the house and
>> Oh, I actually don't cook and clean >> Oh, I don't
cook. I don't clean. Let me tell you. I got this ring. Okay.
So, I try to cook like maybe once a week, but since I've been
making content and Tik Toks, that hasn't really been happening.
But no, we have like a cleaning lady come once a week because
also like cleaning is hard and it's really stressful and it >> Oh,
I told you. I called that. That's super obvious, right? When
when everybody talked about how it was like dirty in there. I
think we're watching AB and Preach and I'm like, "Bro, you think
this cleans?" Yeah, they got a maid. Of course they've got a
maid. Of course they have a maid. Of course she doesn't clean
up. >> Damages your cuticles and your nails. if you spend
like x amount of money on the nail salon, it's kind of a waste
to like [__] up your manicure. That's how we kind
of split that. We outsource, which I truly believe in. And then
for laundry, like [laughter] >> yes, outsourcing is how
things are done in the modern day. >> I do my own laundry.
He does his own laundry. So, when we first moved in together,
I was doing both of ouries together. Worst mistake of my life.
His clothes made my clothes so smelly. The smell is unreal because
the balls. No offense to the homeless people, but like you know
when you get on the subway and there's like a homeless person
sleeping and like everyone has to get out of that car. Yeah,
>> that's what my husband's balls smell like. Oh my god.
[laughter] I hope he's
Now let's just for the sake of the analysis. Okay, this is one
of the biggest nothing bers I've ever seen. All of the red pill
man were triggered by this. It's a hugely innocuous joke about
his balls. It's just a my husband bad joke that we've been hearing
for decades.
Act made far more worse jokes about his genitals. Wait, what?
What is this? Six years ago. Wait, what? Horrible decisions.
31-year-old virgin Akos Singh. Featuring Akos Singh. What? >> What?
To do it. We got good vibes going. Me and this [__]
getting money.
>> Wait, what?
That's crazy. Six years ago, uh, 2020
after Jasine says she was a virgin. And Akos says that's what
Oh, so she said she was a virgin, too. Okay, just to be clear,
she's also said she was a virgin. So, I guess the idea would
be that her content is all a lie. Is it 2020 there? >> At
the point where I was ready cuz I don't know if you told her
cuz I was >> Oh, I know. I didn't know you were a virgin,
too. >> So, I was a virgin, too, when I met him. >> So,
this is a this is not a bit that they were going back on, right?
Or sorry, this is not a bit that they were like setting up. This
is them doing a random tiny podcast six years ago with totally
irrelevant people and this is the story they're telling. Right?
So the idea that people are like, "Oh, it's just a bit like they
they set this up for rage bait." No, they didn't. They didn't
just set up for rage bait. This is like legitimately the at least
this story was one they were being consistent on and she's just
lying about it. >> That's why she don't know the dick is
trash. [laughter] >> That's why >> she don't know
no better >> and you have no idea. >> You got to
get him ignorant. You know what I mean? >> No. So, I felt
like I was like at a place where I was right. >> Yeah.
Her her and Akos are on the same podcast here. Yeah.
Well, this is the spotting clip right >> It's weird about
periods. That's a red flag. Break up with him immediately. No
pun intended because when I was in college, I dated this guy.
You know, he didn't want to fool around when I was on like the
heaviest days of my period. Okay, totally understandable. I get
that. And I was like, "Oh, great. Good news. My period ended.
Like, we can like have fun tonight." blah blah and he was going
down on me. >> Okay. I mean, is she just saying that anything?
I feel like they're just going to go to the Oh, no. Well, I didn't
get I didn't have with anybody. I just got eaten out, I guess.
>> Dude, Abba and Preach
ate so badly on this content. This content like literally bought
ABBA another like another nuclear shelter, another doomsday shelter.
Okay, just just this content alone. That's it.
Crazy stuff. All right, let's get back to the main [laughter]
podcast.
So, when she says like, "No, I was a version. I didn't." I don't
know, man. What are you saying? It's not a bit because she's
had I'm saying that this wasn't just rage bait because I think
she's genuinely talking about having college and stuff. She's
either lying, right? Lying just for like fun to lie to people.
Finish the clip. Oh, you want me to finish the clip? Hold on.
is weird about periods
going around down there. >> Okay, hold on. Let's keep watching.
>> Looking around down there, like more blood can sometimes
come out even if your period is over. I swear to God, like I
thought my period was done. He like looked at me with so much
disgust
>> and I'll never forget that moment. Like I felt so ashamed.
>> Wait, but we we don't need anything else from this clip.
We're just going to say like no, she was like she was definitely
involved in college. That's all we're >> She was so dirty
and like he was like how could you do this to me and all this
stuff ruined the night and like whatever. And we he was my boyfriend
at the time. I was just like so depressed. I went home and like
I called my sister and I was like I have to tell you something
like this happened to me. And she literally was like so
>> and I was like what do you mean? She was like I don't
know what you're saying. so normal like >> so my question
is my question is my >> it sounds fake.
Okay. All right.
Um maybe I feel like the more reliably or understandable thing
is that this girl she says oh I was the innocent Indian girl
in college.
Okay. I was like I was repressed and then I I lived my best life.
That always means one thing. But you're yeah you're you know
you're probably right. This girl probably went through college
a total virgin. She's getting eaten out and she was like, "No,
no, no. You can't put it in." Definitely not. 100%. 100%. That's
definitely what happened. Yep. You guys are about as discerning
as a good luck. [laughter]
>> Doesn't she end it by saying I needed >> That's
so normal. Like, >> so my question is my question was to
>> Oh, no. No.
>> All these
got up and kissed you. Did you swerve >> I didn't listen.
Are they done with that
>> A girl to sign a prenup. Incredibly
>> I don't think she stop. I don't think she ended by saying
she needed I was like meing when I said that. I kind of hinted
at that, but I I was not being serious.
[laughter] >> Well, let's get a counter argument. Let's
get a counter argument, okay? Because I think that was inappropriate.
That was uncalled for. So, will you go ahead and dismiss this
and uh explain yourself on the record? >> Do things.
[laughter] >> All right. Look, my client in this case,
that's not what she said. >> Can you be Jasine's lawyer
in this moment here?
>> Jaseline Cook,
>> when do you guys think she Akos found out she ain't
no virgin? I mean, I assume he found out like as of uh two years
ago, a year ago, at some point when she started talking about
it, but they're they're just redoubling down on the virgin thing.
I feel like it's unlikely, but hey, maybe >> she cleans
she maintains the home on a monthly basis. Is that true? >> Yes.
There you go. >> Not by me specifically. >> I mean,
people are saying poo pole loophole. It sounds like that is the
most reliably or understandable thing. Like it sounds like that's
legitimately maybe what we're going with here. Maybe. >> But
yes. >> Yes. And you also will find people, but not you.
You schedule. Someone got to manage the house. >> We all
have cleaning people.
>> Yes. I like how you called him cleaning people. [laughter]
>> That was very politically correct. >> That was
But do I not take care of Happy Like he's my son? Of course.
And I go on the road, I come back, it's clean. I don't know if
you hire somebody or if that's you, but uh every time I come
back, it's clean. >> I hire someone. Yeah. >> Really?
[laughter]
>> Without me knowing.
>> Now I feel betrayed.
>> I thought you did something. >> See, everyone's
hiring people. >> Also specifically said she had no previous
partners on that podcast. Yeah, I'm guessing they're living in
a western country. Why would they be virgins necessarily? Because
they said they were virgins. Aasha said multiple times, it's
really important. It it helped us connect that we were both virgins
when we met. She told him she was a virgin. He said I was also
a virgin. They've talked about it on multiple podcasts for the
past like 8 years, 9 years, okay? All over the place, all over
the internet. And now she's telling stories about how she was
like getting eaten out by some guy and he was grossed out by
her period. She needed to fool around so badly that she couldn't
wait for her period to be over, right? And then we're supposed
to believe that she was just definitely totally a virgin. No
partners. Get the [__] out of here. >> You
know what I mean? Hand jobs, cleaning, doesn't matter. Yeah,
everyone's got something. Outsourcing works. If there's one people
on the planet that understands the [laughter] value of outsourcing,
it should be Indian. This is
>> Yeah. Okay. What else? What else was like super >> more
files? >> Yes. What else is part of Oh, they called it
the Akash files. [laughter] >> They they could release
the AO >> Equivalent to Epstein.
>> Let me Let's think Let's think about it. I'm glad you
asked. >> You're the victim. viewers
>> cuz if they release the files, if you if you address
this, the whole comedy scene is going to come toppling down or
something. I don't know. It was just a cover up. It was a topical
thing. Okay. It's not You're not actually like >> I'm saying
it's files, isn't it? Yeah, but you're >> Akashic record.
Yeah, that would have been better. Nobody gets the Akashic record
joke, though. Andrew Wilson would get it. I see him reference
the Aashic record all the time for some reason. I don't know
why. >> The girls >> I know. Uh akashic record is
I believe the library of all human knowledge possibly from all
times.
It's like a it's somewhere you go in like a dream state in like
a astral projection,
right? And you you get all human knowledge is there. Yes.
>> Yes. The epsylene 5. >> The epsil. Yes. >> Okay.
What else? What else was there? >> Tell me something. >> Because
this has been bothering me. >> I love the that this is
so good with the
>> Great character work. I'm sorry to break >> Thank
you. Yeah. Silence. [laughter]
>> Tell me something. When Akos is sick, how do you behave?
she's good. Actually, I really am. >> I am good. >> Yeah.
Oh, my wife is horrible. >> There's an undertone of irritation
after like day two where you can tell she's >> "All right,
[clears throat] let's
>> Okay. Can I just say I feel like you guys are a little
bit like you guys exaggerate a lot and just >> No. On average.
And for context, >> we exaggerate.
>> I'm sorry.
This is See, she's doing a genius thing here. Okay, this is a
debate bro tactic. She's saying, "Oh, guys exaggerate when they're
sick a lot." The framing here should be
I said I I literally support everything. I get to be I get to
be a bit dramatic when I'm sick. That should be Akasha's line.
Okay,
Bro, I'm like I'm I'm get to be a little dramatic. I get to be
a little melodramatic. That gets to be me when I'm sick. That's
what Akash should be should be saying here. Okay.
>> Oh, you think everything's wrestling? Do you think that
>> everything's a joke? >> You think we're just going
crazy? >> We're not taking any chances here. Do you see
our security?
[laughter] >> Do you know what the [__] you're
capable of, Justine? >> But like for me, like an hour before
my emergency go
>> I'm looking around. So, Akasha's birthday
to the bit. Plus, I I think I'll do a little bit more. Some of
these stories I don't really Some of the stories I don't care
about the explanations for. Like her just being like like not
wanting to have him get take to just want to be taken care of
all the time. I'm like whatever. I don't care. It's a personality
quirk. He's he's fine with it. You were probably like that the
whole time you're together. Like it seems like he's fine with
that. >> Most of the stuff that he's like totally fine
with I don't really care about. It's the stuff that he seemed
like kind of weird about although possibly into and then playing
up the humiliation. And then the it's not even the financial
stuff. It's the the stories like her not being a virgin. That's
the stuff that I think is like pretty crazy. We winding down
or another hour. Um I don't know. What do we What are we at here?
Yeah, probably like six, seven subs for another hour if we wanted
to do that. I I could like grab some caffeine and we could do
more content if you guys wanted. If you guys want to pay for
more time. I do six subs. I do 30 bucks. Again, I've got What
do we got here? We've got Fuentes, Candace. No, I don't really
care about that. Oh, we could do the the Pisco Stale stuff.
And then, oh, I have all the Grace Lo stuff, too. Grace Lo and
Lav. We have like a bunch of tweets on that stuff. That could
be funny. Could be interesting. And there's something else that
I'm forgetting, but I can't remember. Oh, Milo Tucker. Milo >> birthday
comes around.
>> I have to pretend that it's like so special. But >> I
don't even ask for this. >> The one day. Yeah, you do.
The one day of the year that I have to like be totally selfless.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. That >> would piss on steal or
something. Well, apparently, so Stale went on there. Stale is
just a like he's not capable of arguing anything. So, you got
totally mogged. It was very easy to see how he get mogged. Oh,
Crowder and Fentes might be good, too. I didn't I didn't watch
any of the Crowder Fentes stuff. I saw they talked I saw some
of the stuff from that, but I didn't uh I didn't actually watch
the content. So,
so there's the stale stuff and then but I heard after stale there's
an even better call where somebody's arguing about Ethan and
they're like a totally deranged freak. So, which is really hard.
[laughter] >> Yeah, Jessine, you're doing a horrible job
right now. >> Justine just >> Okay, let's go. Let's
go to the next
>> It's a Akash's birthday fleeing to India. No, no, no,
no. Committing to the >> Okay, so you go to the temple.
It's >> You're able to pray. Is Akash fully converted to
see? No. He's getting there, though. >> She She goes to
the mother probably. She makes me go more than I make her. >> Sitch
said it was terrible. I don't know. Oh, the Fuentes Crowder thing.
Probably. I'm I'm sure Crowder sucks in like every way possible.
>> She's like, "We're going to the Golden Temple. We should
go to the Gdora. We should also go to the Mund." And I I'm kind
of like, "I'm tired. Let's just do >> But which one would
you do? >> I would do the M. >> The over the Gdora.
But you get free food at the Gora. >> You do get free food.
>> You see the L? Mark knows. You did a video. [laughter]
>> Yeah, we had the food at your wedding. That was great.
>> Peanut butter stuff. >> What was it? >> Which
part? Oh, the pashad. >> It's brown sugar, ghee, and flour
like mixed together. She's actually made a nonconizing
a horrible way. >> Okay, so you can make all these things.
You can make all these things.
>> So, you're presenting this this version of yourself
online. That's not true. >> But you're actually a trad.
>> I was committing to this a bit cuz I thought that that
was the funny thing to do, but I'm not a comedian. Obviously,
>> you're not fooling us. Yeah. >> All right. Actually
funny. >> All right. Let's [laughter] let's rank Asian
people. Okay. This is not
don't do it. Don't do it. Okay. Some of these questions she might
answer and then she might get in trouble in a different way.
Can I ask you a question? >> Black people. >> Okay.
No, not that question. You remember this? So, this is people
always say like that Monty's and stuff say she's just like my
mom and I'm realizing wait you remember my mom. You ask her anything
and she like I don't want to answer that. And then she'll answer.
So, I'm realizing she does exact >> Oh, was that kicks?
Did I just hear kicks come through? Is that the ding for kicks?
Hamster with 500 kicks. Let's go. Thank you very much, hamster.
Appreciate >> Maybe that's why they get along so well.
If you ask these questions, she will >> Your mom hit me
up. [laughter] Your mom hit me up when you were going through.
>> Oh, yeah. Dude, she's told me. She's like, I subs. Five
subs for the hour. >> I told him my daughter-in-law is
so nice. [laughter] >> So sweet. I was like, oh my god.
>> She's like, I promise she was a virgin. I promise. I
was like, I'm not getting involved in this at all. He's like,
I know. I can smell it. I was like, what is that? [laughter]
>> What the what the
>> Anonymous, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. >> But
she was she was working. She was working PR for you. I just want
to let you know. But I never doubted it. >> I never [laughter]
doubted it. Type a comment on the YouTube. She had it sent it
to me long. Yeah, a long one. I was like, you don't need to do
all this. Yeah, that was probably the best. >> What do
you guys say? Some people say this is a whole PR stunt for you
to sell tickets and for you to >> Oh, is that rather stunt?
Yeah. >> Is that a
Oh, that now you're [laughter] a couple videos saying it's like
a very strategic PR stunt. I don't know how >> I wish.
Uh, hmster. Thank you very much for the 20 months. Let's go.
>> I wish. >> Lean in. Lean in. Say you're going
to kiss at Radio City. >> M. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> We sell radio station. We will make out >> April
18th.
[laughter] radio signup. A postup.
>> Okay, fire into this. I'm into this. >> Have you
seen any memes or content that you guys thought were funny? >> Uh
Aisha Chicken Curry. >> That was [laughter] the funny objectively.
Good. Yeah. >> I also like Aisha
>> Okay. The next one after all the laughing is the uh
[laughter] >> clip we were just talking about. Okay.
So guys, this is comfortable. But
>> she betting that her husband is so bad at his job. I
don't even know what you mean. I Man,
>> yeah. I don't know what you mean there. >> no,
I got to turn his cheek. >> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter] Yeah.
Okay. Was there Before we wrap this up, was there anything that
you saw? Was there anything that like obvious
>> um how is there so much laughing when nothing is actually
funny? I hate these people. Once you get a big enough audience
with a dedicated following, you just do your thing and you just
like shape reality to what you want it to be,
>> Oh, if you celebrate this event, I'll sign a post up.
I see. >> Anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Let's
go.
>> What am I trying to say here? I think I think when when
they do this, it's like you you basically can just make your
audience think something. If you signal that it's funny, they'll
they'll laugh. They'll think it's funny, right? A lot of people
listen to this stuff without even really listening. A lot of
people throw this on the background. They don't really listen.
They just go like, "Oh." They just listen for like tone indicators,
right?
So, anybody who's listening to who's watching this with like
a critical eye is seeing like stupid,
but anybody who's like just listening to this in the background,
not really paying attention. They just hear like the laughing.
Everybody's having a good time. Oh, things must be good. Obviously,
all the things I imagine made you feel bad. Was there anything
that specifically bothered you or Yeah, >> I mean I think
people talking about the sore butthole story cuz that was more
kind of like an assault story but I didn't want it >> I
mean that is what it was because I didn't think it was super
traumatizing and I had already shared one and I feel like the
internet has a quota for girls of like how many assault stories
they could share regardless of if it's true or not like obviously
I think be like oh every story she tells >> yeah that's
why I didn't want to do that's why I was like oh this happened
I didn't really say it's okay. So, what happened if you don't
mind saying? >> Well, I mean, so I was living in San >> He's
not that girl, is she? She's not that girl who like gets really
drunk at the party. Is like, "Oh, it'd be totally wrong. It'd
be totally wrong if I tried to have sex with some guy." So, she
gets like blackout drunk and is just like, "Maybe he'll do something.
Maybe this is like the way I can get it done." Okay. I hope I
find I hope I find the one Ted Bundy in the crowd. Is she that
person?
Okay, we all know we all know that person. We all know what we're
talking what I'm talking about here. Okay, definitely a blood
thing would happen there [laughter] existing at all. >> I
This is like when Tinder first came out. There was no Bumble.
There was no Hind. I met this guy on Tinder. Whatever. Like we
were like just feeling like the vibes and I stupidly was like,
"Oh, you can sleep over." But like not really wanting to hook
up that much cuz again for me like I was just like, "Okay, maybe
we can make out and just like whatever and cuddle." But then
I guess he like wanted >> Was this guy Indian? >> No,
he was. Yeah, he took it [laughter] very differently than Yeah.
I've learned this translation. >> An Indian guy might understand
what an Indian girl means when she says we're hooking up. It
doesn't mean we're >> There's something >> I think
most American people thrown off by her inviting him over cuz
when I
>> the black guy's like not following the script sometimes.
He's just like is like no that here I'll just reality check you
guys real quick and then I'll go back to laughing and pretending
that this is all >> That usually means oh we're [__]
>> no I know that was again stupid decision on my part.
I was like 21 so it's like I really just like I don't know like
I just was making bad decisions all around so it's like >> but
I was like okay like we'll kiss whatever. I don't remember honestly
I don't even remember too much but I just remember him like trying
to like sneak a finger and I was like no no we're not doing that
but like then the next day like it was like kind of feeling sore
but it wouldn't like if it had been anything else it would you
know [clears throat] that would have been a whole other story.
It would have been like it would have teared something you
>> that was uh that was definitely a guy escalating directly
to that's definitely what happened there. Yeah. >> So it
was >> just like that. >> This was a creep pervert
that was trying you and the internet ran off with this crazy
narrative of something completely different. Yeah. >> Security
unifi. >> Now that that is Hold on. That is like an assault
story though. She presented as an assault story. Like she said,
"Oh, I was like kind of really drunk and I didn't want to say
no to this guy and then I woke up the next morning. I like he'd
done something right." I think that's So that was an assault
story. I don't think that's like a lie here. She was saying basically
I I wasn't planning to do that and then it just happened.
[laughter] we got to get them. >> I would love that.
>> Can Can I beat this guy up? Probably
>> get the rose to his head. You got it.
>> Um, anything else? What other things popped up? >> We
got to get it all out. >> Yeah, we need to get it all out.
>> We need to purge this. >> And I'm not going to
be happy until we figure it out. >> Oh, the dermatologist
video. >> That one pissed me off. That was outrageous and
completely uncalled for. >> So, tell us why you were showing
your cheeks to
be single.
>> Wait, what? >> Doctor, the whole lore. Okay, looking
back, I get it. This it was stupid. I was being stupid. Okay.
Well, we all make mistakes, but [laughter] >> good point.
Technically, we do. >> Yeah. So, what happened was I actually
fell in Pilates. >> Bro, there there are other clips that
exist here that we haven't seen. I don't even know this clip
they're referencing. The dermatologist clip. >> I fell
on my ass. Me and Akash happen to have an amazing romantic weekend
>> Where? What position? Where? Hold on. >> Like
in New York City, just whatever. Enjoying life. And maybe we
had just gotten the rose toy, too. So, it was like also really
[laughter] fun. >> The rose toy.
the roast is inappropriate. Is it a toy for things? >> Yeah,
it makes things very easy and
>> You'll never have to go down again. >> But it's
not. >> This is a conscious.
>> This is my outsourcing. >> You are an enigma though.
Whoa.
>> No. You like you're So what? What? Why? That's a word,
right? >> Just the energy is crazy. [laughter] >> You
haven't seen this? It's pretty crazy. Yeah, I've not seen it.
Um,
okay. Hold on. Hold on. It'll be It'll be here, won't it? Hold
on. Derm dermatologist.
No, it's not here. Hold on. Apparently, we need to see this one.
>> Oh, dermatologist video popped up. Let me see here.
Oh, hooligans with the five gifted. Let's go. It's another hour
on the stream. Uh, I was kind of ready to be done, but now you
guys are demanding another hour on the stream. Let's go. Let's
go. Okay, hold on. I'm looking this up on the other window. Dermatologist
clip. Wait, no. >> I love you guys. It's not this, right?
It's not this. This is a different one.
>> Yeah, that's not That can't be it. >> There's
so much every time you say this. >> No, no, that can't
be it. That's like a skincare routine thing. Nah.
>> Hold on. Let me pop this back. [laughter] I'll keep
you.
>> The hard hotel. >> Okay. An enigma.
Okay. [laughter] Oh god, it doesn't.
YEAH. WHAT IS [screaming] CHILL OUT? [laughter] There's a woman
here. >> No, not that. Just that one. Nothing goes inside.
>> You're comfortable sharing this, >> but then there's
other things you're not >> because I also feel like this
could help girls out. You know, I'm on SSRI, so you need like
a little boost.
>> Dude, she's so uncomfortable with public affection.
It's Hold on. >> Treating my bruise.
>> How do you get this little filter? >> It's a ring
light.
>> Dr. Chro, what are we doing? here. So, Justine sustained
a bruise
through some physical activity at home
and uh we treat a lot of bruises here. Um bruises for many different
reasons. [laughter] And so, we have an external laser called
the Vbeam. It's a vascular laser. So, it targets just the hemoglobin.
What's awesome is
>> Well, she's basically got her though, right? This guy's
going to go fix her bruise on her ass. for is completely removed
from anywhere from 24 to 48 hours. Ready? >> Also, I heard
your
>> All right, we're going to go back to
>> Wait, this you think this one's like the worst one?
I think this [clears throat] is not the worst one. This one's
like clearly a joke. At least this one This one's just a joke.
I don't know. I don't think that's the worst one. Come on, man.
Come on, man. Why not? Yes. This is But this is why I think that
there's confusion. To feel comfortable talking about that, but
then also not feel comfortable things. That's where the brain
goes. What? I have to make up >> I don't know. It's hard
for me. I mean, >> sure. I will say that it is maybe the
the thing that seems weird here is her like totally asymmetrical
discomfort with stuff. Stuff talking about her husband. It seems
like it's way out of bounds. Uh she's very uncomfortable talking
about it. Stuff involving like her and other guys very much inbounds.
Very much okay. Very much like everything we're talking about.
>> I just am existing. I'm not trying to like The only
thing I try to do is just be myself on TikTok, but like 10 times
extra. And again, like not to justify, but I feel [laughter]
I've been out guys since I'm 22. And I feel like I've learned
so much of my humor from him, my
>> Wait, she's 22?
She can't be Wait, she's not 22. What? >> Wait, since I'm
just being myself on TikTok, but like 10 times extra. And again,
like not to justify, but I feel like I've been with since I'm
22. And I feel like >> Oh, I missed it. I've been with
Ash Akos since I was 22. Yeah, because she's like 30. She graduated
in 2016. Like that's she's she's older than 22. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. That would be a crazy thing to say. >> I've learned
so much of my humor from him, my personality from watching you
guys. I've hung out with so many comedians, so I'm like, "Oh,
like be extreme. Be funny." As long as your actions are a good
person. You know what I mean? So I'm like, "Oh, I can say whatever
I want." >> Don't you blame this on us. [laughter] >> Can't
blame this on us. >> I'm trying to give context. I'm not
blaming anything. >> Fair. The uh Okay. So, you were saying
you guys had a really horny weekend with your toys. Yes. Okay.
And so what happened was as a joke on TikTok, I showed the bruise
like not like I didn't show my full cheek, but I just show a
little bit cuz again like repressed Indian girl. I'm like, "Oh,
I can dress however I want as long as I don't actually do anything."
So I'm like, "Okay, you know, show tell me you had a good weekend
with your husband without telling me." He showed the little bruise.
Richie, who is my dermatologist and my brother, amazing like
practitioner. He was like, "I've gone to him for hyperpigmentation.
It really bugs me." And he's like, "Hey, I just want to let you
know if you don't treat this, this is going to pigment." And
then he knows he's going to have to deal with me later. Like
please, can you get rid of the scar? So he's like, "I would just
treat it like ASAP or whatever." So I'm like, "Okay, perfect.
I'll come in." And then again, me being stupid, like cuz I want
to go on double dates. I'm like, "Oh, he's single." And I'm like
having like this like tongue-in-cheek thing of like kind of alluding
to me and Akash having even though I actually found Pilates.
So the whole thing was taken out of context.
couldn't even let him have that one. E couldn't even let him
have that one.
>> I never said I had strong, if anything, affirming for
me. >> But did that make more sense like to the context?
Yes, of course. But at the same time, the the issue is always
like people's perception. >> Yeah, the perception. >> I
think the the big disconnect with you is like and also there's
a version with both of you is it you guys are so innocent cuz
you've never been with anybody. So when you say weird things,
you think it's absurd, but you are unique in your innocence with
each >> I think that was the mistake I made is like thinking
that people would understand that like they will not. Yeah, they
won't. >> Because the immediate reaction to anybody like
who's had cuz Alex and I Mark is more similar to you guys. >> Mhm.
and let you know he's been with his wife, right? So, it's like
whereas Alex and I have, you know, we've had other chicks and
like our, you know, wives have had as well. And then we got to
think about that a little bit.
>> Exactly. Yeah. But like, so then we we're there [clears throat]
is a part of us probably. >> Okay. I'll be honest. This
is like fine. I mean, it's not fine. It's It sucks. Like, this
podcast sucks. Their relationship, whatever. They do what they
want to do. Um, I think I think clearly he is uh like
I have a hard time taking him seriously when he still clings
to the virgin thing. I think it's pretty obviously not true.
In my opinion, it's like obviously not true, but whatever. Whatever,
man.